- Le restaurant Le Mousso
au centre-ville de Montréal
a fait un grand virage
au cours des derniers mois.
- - Ça nous donne
une meilleure qualité de vie.
- Le propriétaire,
Antonin Mousseau-Rivard,
ne l'ouvre maintenant que trois
soirpapar semaine et les postes
de serveurs ont été abolis
pour donner, entre autres, un
meilleur salaire aux cuisiniers.
ANTONIN MOUSSEAU-RIVARD,
propriétaire, Le Mousso
- Ce métier-là, je l'adore,
mais il m'a mis à terre
2-isisis.
- Le propriétaire du restaurant
Au Pied de Cochon, lui,
Martin Picard, a essuyé
un flot de critiques
pour avoffffffiché
un poste de cuisinier avec
un salaire de 13,50 $ l'heure.
Il s'est défendu, prétextant
qu'avec les pourboires,
ses employés auxeaux
gagnent plutôt autour
de 18 $ l'heure.
ELIZABETH NORMAND,
employée en restauration
- C'est fréquent f f fait,
que les salaires soient
très bas dans les restaurants
les plus haut de gamme,
et souvent, toutes les heures
qu'on fait sont pas pa
non plus.
- Cette cuisinière a quitté
Montréal après avoir travaillé
dans plusieurs restaurants
dont le Toqué! La plupart,
dit-elle, n'offrent pas
de bonnes conditions de travail.
- Les restaurateurs, ils font
pas des salaires énormes,
ils vivent pas dans
des châteaux, ils se promènent
pas en Rolls-Royce. Ils sont
les premiers à mettre des heures
de travail extraordinaires
pour, eux, retirer peu d'argent.
- Justement, le modèle
doit changer.
- Le professeur en gestion
de l'ITHQ, l'Institut
de tourisme et d'hôtellerie
du Québec, explique qu
moyenne, pour 100 $ de revenus,
un restaurateur paie environ
34 $ pour la nourriture,
33 $ pour la main-d'oeuvre,
18 $ pour le l
et 10 pour d'autres frais,
si bien que la marge de profit
ne dépasse que très rarement
5 %. L'une des solutions serait
d'augm p p p p prix des plats,
ce que plusieurs refusent
de faire.
FRANÇOIS PAGEAU, professeur de
gestion en restauration, ITHQ
- Si il y a pas de clients,
ntntntntnt, il y a pas
de business. Donc, il faut
d'abord s'assurer d'avoir
de l'achalandage. Et pour
assurer cet achalandage-là,
on veut maintenir les prix
le plus bas possible.
- Mais au Mousso, un repas pour
deux peut coûter jusqu'à 900 $.
c'c'c'c'c'c'est sûr qu'on offre
plus que 13,50. Même un salaire
de base de plongeur est...
est plus élevé que la moyenne
des salaires de cuisiniers
de base.
- Un changement de culture
pourrait bien être en train
de s'opérer.
Ici Sebastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montréa